in less than 10 minutes you are going to
equip with a high-profile trap against
the London system which you can apply
instantly and get some cool
victories after D4 I am going to
Advocate you start with the Queen's
Gambit decline structure with either of
the mo order let's say D5 Bishop to F4
Knight to F6 E3 and now E6 this
trademark Queen's Gambit decline
structure whereupon if you look at the
database kn2 F3 has been exclusively
played here and this straightway enter
into the classical London system where
of course black has tried many moves but
my move is not even in top 10
choices are you ready for the surprise
just look at this guys Knight to
E4 what a move and by playing this not
only we centralize over Knight but as
happened in Manny case some of the Top
Choice from the database let's say
Bishop D3 C3 or C4 run straight away
into our trappy
territory now before I show you the Trap
one important point I like to mention
that white can avoid this trap by
playing either Knight B2 D2 or H3 but in
that case black get a very easy set up
and I'm going to demonstrate those lines
at the end so make sure you watch the
video Until the
End after Database Top Choice Bishop to
D3 here comes the move which sets up the
amazing trap and that is
G5 so we are attacking the bishop and
accordingly white has few choices number
one if Bishop to E5 that doesn't change
the story as after F6 Bishop to G3 and
the move H4 more or less this enter into
the main line so that's why by far at
this point the main move is Bishop to G3
and no surprise for Black's next move
H5 where actually we are threatening to
take down this poor
baby okay white has to do something and
F blender they can make over here is
Bishop to E4 after this the simple
sequence Pawn takes E4 attacking the
Knight Knight to D2 H4 Bishop E5 and F6
what else winning the piece at just
ninth move of the game so that variation
is right out of the
equation white will play either the move
H3 or H4 let's say H3 is a Top Choice
and in that case now we see the point of
centralizing of Knight as we can chop
this bishop give white this horrible
Pawn structure and now the easiest plan
in the picture is Bishop to D6 and
Target that juicy G3 Pawn okay white has
two options if you play Knight to E5
this is worst because we can play Knight
to D7 and please note this Knight cannot
move as the G3 Pawn drops with a check
so accordingly White's best move here is
to Castle on the king side after this
black can simply Vince the pawn and
emerge with a great Advantage from this
position
okay that is about Knight to E5 what
about King to F2 trying to save the pawn
well more or less same story this time
black has a very strong move Queen to F6
and our threat is G4 so white has to
play G4 whereupon I propose this simple
sequence E5 trying to get the piece so
white has to take it now we take with
the bishop and threat is on on B2 so
accordingly white has two choices if you
play Knight to C3 then you can play C6
and the resing positions are quite good
for the black so in one game my 2400
rated opponent continue with C3 trying
to defend this threat but what he missed
is Pawn T G4 Pawn T G4 Rook exchange and
now very simple move Bishop takes G4
where I have a very simple idea and that
is Knight to D7 and Castle on the queen
side where if you look at the white
position not only he's a pawn down but
his King hardly described as a safe
peace okay what about H4 well the same
story goes we take on G3 Pawn takes G3
and this time we can even play G4 and
harass this Knight after Knight to E5 I
simply propose you continue with Knight
to D7 attacking this Knight so white has
to take this Knight but after Bishop
takes D7 and the move C5 once again
black emerged with a completely
dominating position in this line the
point is you are threatening C4 so white
has to play C3 and now let me
demonstrate a Grandmaster game from here
where black really tricked white with
Queen to B6 attacking on B2 white
thought B3 will compromise his quein
side so he played Queen to C1 but after
Bishop to D6 King to H2 black played
just one move and white get a completely
lost position I wonder if you can spot
it congratulations if you find the move
Queen to
d8 well the threat is very simple Queen
takes H4 and even though white can see
this one is coming he can hardly stop
it now as I promise let's check out what
happens if white doesn't fall for the
trap with the move Knight B2 D2 well
after this I propose this very simple
sequence first you capture this Knight
then you play Bishop to D6 so if white
exchange then we are more than happy so
most of your opponent continue with
Bishop to G3 and exactly here we play B6
and as you can see from the arrows very
simple yet very effective plan of
campaign by the Black and it doesn't
matter how we were white
plays Black equalizer cannot be
denied recently I achieve this position
against a Grandmaster where the game
continues like this my opponent plays
Bishop to D3 I simply continue with
Bishop to B7 and after C3 Queen to E7
and because I was weaker than him he
decided to Castle on the queen side
after this we know what is coming yep
Knight to
D7 okay white plays Queen to C2 at6 and
now because black king is caught in the
center White open the center with E4 and
here we have the massive exchanges Pawn
takes E4 Bishop takes E4 Bishop takes E4
and queen takes E4 of course at the end
black cannot Castle on the queen side
but I can do Castle on the king side and
just look at the engine Evolution here
it says it's completely balanced and
whoever play better obviously he's going
to win the match of course I lost the
game in the time scramble but I must say
if a Grandmaster cannot do anything to
me until 30 40 moves then the opening is
a huge
success that's it guys I hope you like
this super surprising line against
London system I insist you to try this
on the different chess website and give
a very hard time to passive London
player thank you for watching this feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon bye and take
care